[MUSIC PLAYING]
TREFFYN KORESHOFF:
Hello, Hello, hello.
Welcome to I/O day two.
My name is Treffyn Koreshoff.
I'm a UX researcher
here at Google,
and that means
that I get to talk
to end users about how they use
different cool things online.
But before I can talk
to people about how
they use the great things
that you're building,
I often have to take them
through some sort of a sign-in
or account creation moment.
And that's what this talk
today is really about;
it's about making those
sign-in and account creation
moments a little less painful
and a bit more magical.
So if you use a
username and password
as part of your sign-in
or account creation
moment in what you're
building, then you
are in the best possible place
you could be at I/O right now.
No matter whether you work
more on the product development
side of things, in
which case we've
got some great UX to show
you which will help increase
conversion for valuable users--
gets a smiley.
Whether you're on
the development side,
where we've got some cool code
snippets and libraries that
will help make Google Identity
integration to what you're
building extremely simple.
Or whether you, like
hopefully we all
do, care about the
security and privacy
of what you're building, we'll
take you behind the scenes
and show you some
of the security
that goes into Google Identity
and what data is shared.
Even if you have no
registration flow at all,
I'd actually encourage
you to stick around
because we think that you'll
see some cool things today
that you may want to
add to your site anyway.
So I'm just here
for an introduction,
and as part of that, I'd like
to share with you the top four
things that annoy me about
sign-in and account creation
moments.
Now not to give
the punchline away,
but these are all four
things that Google Identity
can help you with.
So to start off, friction.
Let's imagine that
your user has just
got a new phone, new
device, and they're
signing back into everything.
At this point they're
probably thinking--
and you may have had this
experience-- probably thinking,
what was that username
and password again?
Well they wouldn't be alone.
Hawaii's governor has
certainly had this issue.
Perhaps some sign-ins are more
consequential than others,
but you know, he can sympathize.
So to get around the remembering
your username and password,
maybe you decide to add this
Sign-in with Google button
or something similar to help
your users not have to remember
their username and password.
Well this is great,
but what happens
if we can get rid of this whole
sign-in screen altogether?
It might look a little
something like this.
Your user arrives on
your site or your app
for the first time, new
phone, and they're just signed
immediately straight back in.
I know it can be a bit hard to
see down at the bottom there,
so here it is a bit bigger.
People arrive on your site
and they're just automatically
signed straight back in.
Let's just skip the whole
sign-in screen altogether.
But of course, this
isn't just about sign-in,
it's also about
account creation.
And account creation has
huge drop off sometimes.
And this can be for
a variety of reasons,
but even for a short, short
sign-up form like this one,
we see drop off of 40% or more.
Now you might be hoping
that your users have
some sort of password autofill,
and that's great if they do,
but even if they do,
you're still taking them
out of the flow, out of
what they were doing,
to a separate sign-up page.
Not ideal.
So what happens if we could
take this whole sign-up process
and move it into one click,
and they're into the site.
So again, here I'm showing
it to you on the first page,
the first time somebody opens
your app, but the magic of this
is that you can take this
and place it wherever it
makes most sense in your flow.
It doesn't have to
be at the beginning
when they first
arrive, it can be
wherever they have most
intent to create an account.
So it is one-tap,
contextual account creation
where it makes
most sense for you.
The second thing--
well actually,
just briefly an example from
somebody who has integrated
this-- it was Redfin--
who had an 80% increase
in the number of new users
once they introduced this
one-tap, seamless contextual
account creation.
Now the second thing that
annoys me is security.
If you look at the
passwords that people
use online these days,
not only are they weak,
they're often
re-used and they're
susceptible to phishing.
Now we're going to deep dive
into the security behind this
like I mentioned,
so I'm not going
to go into it too much here.
Suffice to say that Google
Identity can help with this,
and it's the same--
again, not give
away the punchline--
but it's the same security
that we use for Google accounts
on Google.com.
The third thing that can annoy
me about sign-in and account
creation is quality.
You spend a lot
of time and money
getting people to
your site or app,
and maybe they convert, maybe
they change into a user,
but how many of your
accounts look like this?
Maybe this is an
extreme example,
but even if a real person
with a real email address
comes to your site, they
may not be as engaged
as you'd like them to be.
And we hear time and
time again from people
who's used Google Identity
that Google users are not
only more engaged
on their platform,
but they create less spam.
So at this point, you might
be thinking, OK, great,
this sounds great.
I can see some UX
improvements I'd
like to maybe see a
point for in my site,
it comes with great security,
and you're telling me
it helps keep the quality
of the accounts high.
I'm building a cool thing,
I don't have time for this.
To which I would say
that we have worked
really hard to get
everything you've just seen
and more available to you
in just a few lines of code.
Again, we'll take
you through that
in the second half of this.
So just a really quick recap.
Sign-in and account
creation moments
can be some of the most
valuable for your account,
for your sites, but they're
often the most frictionful.
Why don't we replace that
with one-tap account creation
and automatic sign-in?
Security is in the
news a lot lately.
Feel free to use Google's.
You spend a lot
of time and money
getting people to your site,
so give yourself an advantage
and get engaged, active users.
And lastly, do away with
all of the maintenance
for these screens for just
one or a few lines of code
that you implement once.
So these are just
a few of the things
that Google Identity
can help you with.
That's all I'm going to
talk you through today.
But I'd like to
invite three people up
on stage who are going to talk
you through how you can get
this yourself, some
other examples of places
that this has worked,
and also how it works.
I'd like to invite Luke,
Naveen, and Steven up on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
NAVEEN AGARWAL:
Thank you, Treffyn.
My name is Naveen
Agarwal, I'm the end lead
at Google's Federated
Identity Team.
And I have been in this space
from the beginning when you
couldn't use all this magic.
And here is Luke, who is
a new product manager.
And Steven, who has been in
this space for a long time.
So Luke, you were telling
me that you're not
convinced about all this magic.
LUKE CAMERY: Yeah,
that's right, Naveen.
Hi, I'm Luke.
I'm new here and I'm still
figuring all this out.
So one of the things I'm
really curious when I first
heard about this whole
Federated Identity thing
was what the user
experience is like.
How does this magic really work?
NAVEEN AGARWAL: So I think
let's start from the basics.
Lots of people say, what's
this magic within there?
You actually use all these
identity providers every day.
If you have any ID
card in your pocket,
that means you use
an identity provider.
A driver's license, your
employee ID, or a passport.
And what happens is they carry
some information about you,
and you go to a
place where they want
to verify some information,
what do you do?
You take out the ID
card which they accept.
You show it to them
and they verify
that it has the
right attributes,
it's the right ID card, you
haven't tampered with it,
and then they let you in.
And what happens in the
online world nowadays,
the state is pretty different.
You go to a brand
new site, they say,
hey, we need to create
a new ID card for you,
and then we are going
to verify who you are.
And look at what it would
look like in the real world.
So you go to a bar
they, say wait,
you need to create a new ID
card before we let you in.
What would it look like?
You'd be carrying
a stack of IDs card
on a daily basis,
probably thousands,
and the burden on
each and every shop
would be that they
have to set up
a system to create ID cards
for everybody who walks in.
If they forgot the ID
card, it's a huge cost.
But that's what
everybody does right now
online when they create their
own authentication system.
They say, no, you sign up for
my site and remember a password.
And that's essentially
carrying a separate ID
card for each of the sites.
And if you just replaced it with
a very basic identity provider,
you get a token from Google,
and then they just accept it.
And it's that simple.
And the experience is
fairly straightforward.
You go to a site, you see
one of the identity providers
they accept.
In this case, if you click
on Log in with Google,
you go to your
identity provider,
they generate a card
for the ID you want,
and essentially send it
back through the magic which
we will talk more about.
And you are in.
And it's much more convenient
for the user and for everybody.
And what happens inside the
ID card, many people wonder.
We have created what
we call an ID token,
and it's very similar to
your ID card which you carry.
It has some
information about you
and some cryptographic
information for them
to verify that it is authentic.
And essentially, this is the
ID card which the identity
provider generates.
In essence, it makes
it so much easier
if you're using the
identity which you already
have in the digital world.
Does that help?
LUKE CAMERY: Thanks, Naveen.
That gives me a
really good overview,
but I'm still
really curious what
it's like for our users
going through this.
I know when I come to
the sign-in screen,
there's all these
buttons and I'm not sure
which one to click,
or what happens
if I clicked one last time and
I try and click a different one,
or if I already have a
password on the account.
I'll probably, like
most people, just end up
hitting Forgot
Password and going
through the email reset flow,
because that way I really
know that I'm getting back
into the right account.
Steven, I know you spend
a lot of time thinking
about what our user
experience should look like.
Is there a better way than this?
STEVEN SONEFF: Well, you're
completely right, Luke,
that this user
experience confusion
is one of the top reasons why
sites, apps, and end users
are still using username
and passwords today.
And we've thought
a lot about this.
I'm really excited to
talk about the innovations
we're making in this space.
We're thinking about
new ways to get
users signed in and signed up.
What I'd like to focus
on today is an experience
we call a one-tap
account creation.
Now this is a new way for end
users of Google's Identity
systems to share their
basic information
with a site or an
app that they're
using with a single click.
This can be shown
inline on the page
without the user even having to
navigate to a full login screen
or find the Google
Sign-in button.
Once the user has
tapped, this information
is conveyed to the site or
the app that they're using,
and they're able to log
into an existing account
or help create a new one.
To really illustrate this,
what we're going to do
is switch over to a demo and
show you this in real life.
OK.
So what I've got
here is a version
of Chrome running in the
mobile emulation mode.
So you can see we're
emulating an iPhone device.
So this works across all
platforms, including iOS.
And I have a user
signed in here.
Her name is Elisa.
Now imagine that Elisa
is preparing for a trip
and wants to visit
that site that she
heard about called Hipmunk.
So Hipmunk has this really
cool user interface.
And imagine as she loads
up the Hipmunk site,
she'd like to identify herself
to keep track of the travel
that she's planning
across devices.
Now that UI that I
just mentioned shows up
at the bottom here.
Elisa is able to say that
it's OK for this site
to know who she is without
having to go and find the login
screen, figure out
sign-in, sign-up,
or determine which
button she needs to press
or which one she
pressed last time.
So let's try it out.
With one click, we see that
Elisa's account is active here
on Hipmunk.
And this is a live site.
You can actually go
and try it out yourself
on your phone to
see how it works.
Let's go back to the slides.
Now how does this perform?
Well Hipmunk has
actually come back to us
and told us that
this has dramatically
increased the rate at which
users are creating accounts
with their service, and in
turn unlocking this opportunity
to personalize their
experience across devices.
But it's not just here
on the mobile web.
We've had this opportunity
to streamline and assist
in account creation on
Android for some time.
So if you've been to
our talks in the past,
you might have seen some of the
stats and numbers like this.
By incorporating a one-tap
identity experience,
creating an account with
just a single gesture,
apps like Hotel
Tonight have been
able to improve their book out
and conversion rates by things
like 20% to 30%.
That's pretty phenomenal
for just a simple UX
change, an improvement
to the user's experience.
We appreciate, of course,
that it's not just
about acquiring
these new users who
might be visiting
for the first time;
you have a lot of
existing users.
And it would be really a shame
if all those existing users had
to identify themselves again
and again across devices.
After all, today people
are using multiple phones,
they're using tablets, and
their desktop computer.
And so what we offer
here is the ability
for people who have
used a site or an app
before coming back
to that same service
across platforms to be
signed in without having
to find the login screen.
So let's take a look at an
example of how that works.
We'll switch back
to the demo device.
Now to simulate a new
device, what I'm going to do
is actually switch over
to an incognito tab.
Now you'll notice that
in this incognito tab,
we're in the full
desktop version.
So imagine this is Elisa coming
back on her desktop machine
where she'd like
to perhaps complete
a booking that she was searching
for from mobile earlier.
As you can see, we have a
link to the Hipmunk site,
and what I'd like to do
here is draw your attention
to the top right.
That as imagine Elisa comes
back on the desktop site,
you'll see that her information
is being retrieved by the web
property and used to sign her
in without having to navigate
or even remember to go
through a login flow.
At this point, you can see that
things like her previous search
history are immediately
available right across devices.
So it's really this opportunity
to have people come back
to your site, not have to
repopulate their shopping cart
or redo all of their searches.
They can continue
where they left off
with a shopping cart ready.
So let's switch
back to the slides
and see how this one performs.
So for Hipmunk, it's also
been equally impressive.
The proportion of
users who are using
their site in a signed in state
and getting that personalized
experience has gone way up.
We have other numbers from
folks like Ali Express
really even saying that
their conversion rates go up
for these users who are
signed in automatically.
And to call out one
more stat that we've
seen from Android
over the years,
we've had big apps
like Netflix using
an automatic sign-in experience
with data saved in their Google
account, whether that's the
Google account itself or things
like saved passwords,
and as a result
seeing a dramatic reduction
in the support and inquiry
volumes.
So of course, people who
are signed in automatically
don't have to call
up a help desk
to ask for information
about their subscription
or get back into their
account if they get stuck.
So if you put all
these pieces together,
I think we really are opening
the door for a much better user
experience across
the web and apps.
There's this one-tap
sharing of identity
that streamlines the
experience to say who you are.
There's an automatic sign-in
for people who are coming back
and want to stay signed in.
You don't even have to go
to the login screen anymore.
And finally, it's
the opportunity
to unlock this personalized
experience that
continues across devices.
I'll add one more
thing here, that is
that we still have the
traditional button-based flows.
That's the baseline
that you'll have
to implement across
all platforms
to handle edge cases like when
the user is not signed in.
But really, the hope is
that these technologies
can optimize and improve
the common cases for users
who are visiting
your site or app so
that they never even have to
see the login screen at all.
And hopefully that
will address a lot
of those problems and questions
that you brought up, Luke.
LUKE CAMERY: Thanks, Steven.
That honestly looks
like a far better future
than what I was seeing on
that complicated button-based
screen.
But the same time, I
think a lot of people
still have questions when it
comes to using an identity
provider about data sharing.
When you traditionally go in
through an identity provider,
you have this consent moment
where it's unclear, you know,
will your friends get spam?
Will they be able to send
emails to your contacts?
It's kind of scary
and confusing.
You know, when I sign up
with an email and a password,
I know that the site
only knows my email.
Isn't that a lot safer?
STEVEN SONEFF: Yeah, that's
an important topic these days,
Luke.
And so let's go back to that
one-tap UI that we saw earlier.
The thing I'd like
to emphasize here
is that it's a very limited
set of information that's
being shared with
the site or the app
that the user is
interacting with.
It's only exactly what's shown;
their name, their picture,
and their verified
email address.
Now this is the same
essentially as if
the user typed in this
information manually,
but it doesn't have any of the
problems of typos or mistakes,
and it didn't require
the work of the user
having to manually
verify that they
own an email address by
opening up their mail app
and clicking on a link.
The developer knows that their
actual account, especially
in the case of Gmail addresses,
is active on this device
and they own it.
So what we've done
here is really
thought about separating out
the basic information that's
shared to say who you
are in a login flow
from requests for
additional data
as we saw from the
social sign in days
that Luke just pointed out.
We do appreciate,
though, that there
are a lot of apps and
services out there
that do need and depend
on this additional data.
So for example, you can
imagine an experience
where after you've booked a
flight or some travel plans,
you need to synchronize
this with your calendar.
And it would be
great if you could
have this on an ongoing basis
so you didn't have to manually
keep your calendar up to date.
In an example like
this, a developer
can still ask for
that type of access,
but it comes at a point where
the user best understands why
and how this data will be used.
So it can be asked
for contextually,
just like you've seen
on Android and iOS
where things like access
for contacts or photos
can be presented at the right
time, when people understand
why they're needed.
And when you do go through
the experience as an end user,
you can see that
we're doing a lot here
to make it really clear who
you're interacting with,
what data will be
shared, and how
you might see the terms and
conditions the data will
be used under, or even revoke
or control access in the future.
If you put all these
pieces together,
I think we're really trying
to improve the ecosystem here.
For a long time, we've
had an app review process,
and we're expanding that to
verify who these apps are,
what data they're
using, and making sure
that we have contact information
and the ability to shut them
down if things go wrong.
We'll be expanding that to
things like our one-tap sign-up
to ensure that these powerful
APIs and services are only
used by the developers
who have good intentions.
The last big
concern and question
that comes up in this category
about data is users' control.
Both as a developer and
as an end user, people
wonder, if I use these
Google Identity technologies,
am I becoming
dependent on Google?
Can the data that I provide
to these services only
be accessed by using Google
services, Google Identity APIs?
The answer here is no.
This information is
conveyed to the developer.
It's, as I described
earlier, a shortcut helping
to process this information
over to developer
and bootstrap the experience.
But at the end of the day,
you're still in control
as an end user and a developer.
You can offer other
mechanisms to log in.
As we've discussed, you have
the user's email address.
You can send them an
email with a recovery link
or another way to log in.
You could even accept
other identity providers,
perhaps having things
like a phone number where
you can send a
recovery SMS, or even
accept an entirely different
identity provider to log
into those existing accounts.
They're still users in
the developer's database
and under their control.
So I hope that if you put all
of these pieces together, Luke,
you'll have a better
understanding of what we're
doing to make it streamlined
and clear to the user
that when they share only
identity information,
it's just that limited
piece of information that's
being conveyed.
On top of that, when
additional data is requested,
it's done in a process
where things are vetted,
it's clearer, and the
user has better control.
And finally, users can still
log in at the end of the day
with other mechanisms.
There's no need for them
to be dependent on Google.
I hope that addresses
some of your concerns.
LUKE CAMERY: Thanks, Steven.
I love how transparent it is.
It's this what you see is
what you get model that
makes it really clear to
me what I'm giving over
to the third party.
But I think something that
goes hand-in-hand with privacy
is security.
There's this protocol
going back and forth
between the site and Google, and
when I sign up for an account,
I can create a
really big password
that will really protect me.
I mean, I know your team
spends a lot of time
thinking about security.
Can you explain why this
is safer than my password?
NAVEEN AGARWAL: Yeah,
security is my favorite topic.
Actually this question
we get asked quite often.
Is this less secure?
Is it going to make my
account system less secure?
In order to understand,
just think about every site
has a forgot password flow.
What happens when a user
clicks on Forgot Password?
You send an email, the user then
goes, signs into their email
account, and then find the
email, click on the link,
and they get back
into your account.
Now if you do click Sign-in with
Google button, what happens?
You'll still go back, sign
into your Google account.
Google generates a
cryptographic token,
says, yes, this user
owns this email address.
And then you accept that and
you get back into the account.
The difference is-- they are
pretty equal from a security
perspective.
I would argue there are some
flaws in the Forgot Password
case where somebody
could have forwarded
that email to somebody
else and people
can get back into the account.
In this Sign-in Google,
you know that they actually
own that email address.
But this is just the
security equivalence,
but there is much more
to the account security.
How many engineers on
your site are working
on securing the account system?
Think about that part.
On the Google side,
we actually have
hundreds of engineers
working on just
protecting Google accounts.
And for every login attempt,
we go through a risk-based
analysis based on
many of the signals--
traditional signals, IP
addresses, location--
but a lot of them
which you don't see.
Trying to understand
whether there's
a bot who is trying to sign in
based on the cursor movement,
and so on.
And based on that,
we figured out
whether the risk of that
attempt, is it low or high.
And if it's basically
a risky attempt,
we would ask that user to verify
through secondary channels.
And in cases where the use got
hijacked, they got phished,
we tried to reach out to
the user in different ways.
Even if the hacker had the
right password to that account
and we think the risk is
high, we will not generally
let the user or the hacker
in, and keep the bad guys out.
In those cases, we are
protecting a lot of accounts
and we are spending a lot of
time and energy on doing it.
But that's just right now.
The bigger part is
continued investment.
We were the first one to
launch two-factor auth
for the consumer side, and
that is still phishable
even though you
have SMS recovery.
And we recently launched what
we call Advanced Protection,
if you go search for it, which
is based on a security key
if your account needs much
higher level of protection
that's non-phishable.
Because you cannot give away a
code to the third party site.
We are also working
with internet standards
and other companies to
protect your other accounts
on other sites.
And in the future, we
want to share some data
about the account
so you can actually
use it to make better security
decisions during purchases
and so on.
And the last is as new
services become available,
like Assistant, we
are making it easier
for people to sign in
using their Google account.
So by using that,
you're actually
making Google Identity-- the
security of Google Identity
is closer to what you will get
in the security of your account
system.
So sophisticated security,
we are doing a lot
to prevent hijacking.
And then again, the
new advanced feature.
Does that make you
feel better, Luke?
LUKE CAMERY: That
definitely makes
me feel a lot safer
as a user, that I
can rely on all
of these security
measures Google is working on.
But what about for
the developers?
You know, there's all these
spam and robo accounts
out there, a lot of
fraudulent actors trying
to take advantage of services.
How do I know that taking
Sign-in with Google
doesn't create just another
route for spammers to get in?
NAVEEN AGARWAL: That's
actually a good question.
And this is
something most people
don't think about when they
create their account system.
What happens is, if I
am actually a hacker,
I can create my mail
server and create probably
millions of hacking accounts
on your site very easily.
Google actually
does a lot of work
to prevent creating
mass accounts.
And what happens
is if you just use
Google Identity
on your site, you
are going to get a
lot of those benefits.
We were talking to one of
the large banks just recently
and I asked him to separate
out their accounts based
on the Gmail addresses
and non-Gmail address,
and they were surprised.
They saw eight times
less fraudulent activity
based on the Gmail addresses
than the non-Gmail addresses.
And it's because
all of the security
we are adding on the Gmail
accounts, which is less spammy
and then not letting those
accounts get hijacked.
And not just
keeping them secure,
we find that these users you
are acquiring through the Google
Sign-in are generally real
users and they are more engaged.
So we talked about Redfin having
an 80% increase in sign up.
More than that, we saw
more than 40% of the users
came back five times
in the next few weeks.
And that is much,
much better stats
than you can find within
your own database.
So you're not just
using Google identity
to keep the bad guys out,
but you're also acquiring
much, much better users.
And most of the users who
have an Android phone,
they have a Google account.
So does that make things better?
LUKE CAMERY:
Honestly, that sounds
really great as sort of
a side benefit of using
Google Identity.
But everything that you
guys have talked about
is so complex, there's all
these security features,
there's all that slick UI
on different properties.
You know, how complicated.
It must be really difficult
for everyone in the audience
to build this into their site.
I know you work on this, Steven.
Do you know?
STEVEN SONEFF: Yeah.
So over the years, I've
talked to literally hundreds
of different developers
about integrations like this
and when it comes down to
it, there's two major pieces
to be aware of.
There's the
front-end work to add
UI, to your app, or your
site, or whatever else you're
building, maybe an action.
And then there's some
work on the server side
to take that information
from the app or the site,
look up the user, and provide
that information to the user
to personalize their experience.
So let's dive a
little bit into this.
On the front-end side
of things, you end up
having to show the user either
a traditional Google Sign-in
button, or as we've
discussed today,
try to optimize that
with some of the one-tap
or automatic sign-in UI.
The first time, the user
will give their consent
to share this information.
And at that point, Google is
able to provide you, the app
developer, a token
representing this user,
the digital passport that
we've been talking about.
Afterwards there's
the back-end work,
and we'll dive into
that in a second.
So to illustrate how this
front-end work works,
let's actually switch
over to a demo.
OK.
So I'm back on my machine
here and what I'll do
is I'll take that code that we
just saw in the previous slide.
And this is the API
calls that you're
going to need to incorporate to
add a one-tap UI to your site
or app.
So let's suppose you already
have a Google Sign-in button
and you really want to optimize
this experience by turning it
into the one-click UI.
So what we're
going to do here is
we're going to take this
little snippet of code
and actually show it
running on a real site.
So there's a few
parameters to this API
call asking to show
the Google accounts
and requesting a token.
As a developer, I mentioned that
there is a registration process
that you have to go through
to get access to these APIs.
And what I'm doing here is
showing the configuration
for a real site.
This is actually
one from B&H Video--
they might even be
here at I/O today--
and we certainly talked
to them in the past.
They have their traditional
Google Sign-in button,
but they haven't
included the one-tap UI.
So I'll show them how easy it
is to add the one-tap experience
to their existing site.
Now B&H Photo Video has
this really cool store
in New York where they have all
kinds of electronic gadgets.
They even gave me a tour of
the last time I was there.
And if you can't
make it in person,
you can definitely check
out their app or their site.
And wouldn't it
be so much better
an experience if, visiting
for the very first time
or coming back
across devices, when
you try to see the
information in your cart,
instead of seeing this
little tumbleweed go
through the empty cart
because it doesn't know who
I am, there was an easy way
for the user to get signed in,
signed up, or perhaps,
as you see further
down the page, subscribed
for a newsletter.
This really feels like
the perfect opportunity
to show that one-tap UI that
we've been talking about today.
So to demo how easy this
is, what we're going to do
is load a script
onto the page that
makes this library available.
At this point, I'm
just going to paste
in the code from the
slide and run it here.
Now you see that inline on the
page, this UI has appeared.
As you, the developer, the key
thing for you to think about
is where and when to show
this information to the user.
What's the right time to
ask somebody to sign up?
As you see, it's
really easy to add.
The key thing to think about
is showing it at the right time
so that people want to click.
Now what I'll do here, again
I have Elisa's account active,
I'll click in through.
And you'll see that
the promise resolves.
I get some information
back about who she is,
and it includes this thing
we've been talking about today,
the identity token.
Now it's a big long
string here, and that's
because it's Base64 encoded.
So what we're going to do
is go back to the slides
and talk a little
bit more about what
you do with this information
and how B&H could actually
take this and sign the
user into, perhaps,
their existing account.
Before we get there, let's just
finish up a few points here
on the front-end side of things.
So as I discussed, you need to
register and create a client
ID for your application.
So agree to things like
the terms of service.
And then, not only
do you need to show
the UI at the right
point, you probably
want to check if those existing
users already have an account.
So perhaps before you even show
the one-tap UI on page load,
you probably want to
call a corresponding API
to sign in existing users.
That's the retrieve method here.
Now we've talked a little
bit about this in the past,
that these similar APIs
are available for Android,
and since we're a bit
short on time today
I'm just going to
skip over it here.
But go to
developers.google.com/identity
to see how to do similar things
in your native apps on Android.
One-tap email selection,
including phone numbers,
and automatic sign-in.
All right.
So what do we need to
do with this information
once we've got it?
We have this token
representing the user.
Well we need to send it up to
the app developer's server,
validate the information
in the token,
and then apply some
business logic.
So things like determining
whether this is an existing
user, or helping a user
create a new account.
So for that, let's take a
closer look at the token.
Now I took the token
here and decoded it
so you can see the contents.
It's a JSON web token.
So a JSON dictionary that
contains some information
about the user.
You'll notice that same
configuration, the audience
parameter here, is inline
and the token saying who
this was issued for.
And that's the thing you have
to check to make sure that this
isn't a stolen piece of data.
Just like a passport
in the real life,
you have to make
sure that someone
hasn't taken this and used
it where they shouldn't have.
There's other information
here about when this token was
issued so you can make
sure it's still valid
and make sure that it
hasn't been replayed.
There's the user data
that we described.
And finally, there's
some information
about who issued this token and
how it's been cryptographically
signed so that you can
check the signature
and ensure that it
came from Google
and hasn't been tampered with.
Now as you can
imagine, it starts
to get a little bit
complicated about knowing
all these details,
and so what I'll show
you next are
libraries that you can
use to do all of the
checks and validation
without having to know the
internals of these tokens
or how they work.
So the first thing we need
to do is send the token up
to the server.
The important thing
to call out here
is to make sure to do this
over a secure channel.
This is a user's credential
that will give them
access to their data,
so need to use HTTPS.
Once it's on the
server, as I described,
we'd really strongly
recommend using a library
to validate this token.
It is a standard JSON
web token, so you
could use any library that
allows you to validate
such tokens, but we'd
recommend that you actually
use an identity-specific
one that checks
the identity-specific claims.
We'll have some libraries from
Google specifically designed
for these Google
tokens coming soon
on
developers/google.com/identity.
So once the token's
been validated,
just like the
passport in real life,
you can use the information
that's available there.
And as I described,
the key things
are checking whether this
user has an existing account.
So maybe you'll take the email
address or the Google user ID,
look up that user and see
if there's a matching one.
As we've described, you know
that in the case of Gmail
users, their email address is
actually active on this device
or browser--
they could reset their password
if they had a traditional
password-based account--
and you should let them
into that existing account.
That's the first step.
Now once you've checked
for existing users,
the key thing to do is
help on board new users.
Now you know who
these users are,
you have their identity
information, their name,
their photo, and
their email address,
so you can really
bootstrap the experience.
But depending on the
nature of your application,
you might need to ask
for additional data--
so things like their
location, or their age--
or maybe have them agree
to terms of service.
And that's stuff
that you'll have
to do in the front
end of the app,
so you have to send
some response back
to finish the account
creation process.
At the end of the
day, the hope is
that you can build an
experience like this, as Treffyn
showed at the beginning.
Coming to an app, either
selecting with one tap
or automatically signing
into an existing account,
with that token behind
the scenes replacing
manual authentication and a
traditional sign-in screen.
The takeaway here is
that you can really
focus on building your service.
Adding this front-end pieces
of UI have been simplified.
You apply the
back-end logic that's
intended for your
application, and you
can use libraries to
make this a lot easier.
Before we move on,
I'll add a plug
for one more
important tool here,
and that is Firebase Auth.
So if you're building for
the Firebase platform,
you're a new
developer, or you're
able to migrate in, we
have a complete auth system
that you can use.
So instead of taking
these libraries
and adding them to your
existing auth system,
we can make it a lot
easier by using Firebase.
OK.
So Luke, any last questions
we can help you with?
LUKE CAMERY: Yeah.
That seems great that you
can outsource all the work
to Google by using those
libraries, and as a developer,
I'm totally convinced.
But at the end of the day, we're
trying to help out companies.
How does this make
financial sense
to integrate into your site?
STEVEN SONEFF: That's
one that we always
have to address is that, as
developers, you come to places
like Google I/O and you're
probably really convinced
that there's opportunities
for your auth system.
Things could be done better.
But we also have
to convince people
who are decision
makers and business
stakeholders about identity
being worth investing in.
So we have great stories
from folks like HomeAway
here, who have really leveraged
the Google identity platform
to better know who
their users are,
to be able to personalize
experiences across devices
and get the right
content in front of them
whenever they come back
to their site or app.
And on top of that, it really
introduces this opportunity
that once users found that
right piece of content,
they can transact
and engage with it.
So that's things like smoothing
out the checkout flow.
I mentioned some of
the numbers earlier
about the improvement
in the conversion rates
if you can make
checkout easier, but we
had this interesting stat
recently from Pet Loves
just saying, as a big shopping
site in South America,
that far more of their users are
ending up at the checkout page
already signed in.
They never even needed
to see the login page.
So you get the best of both;
the streamlined experience
of a guest checkout,
but knowing who
that user is, and the
opportunity to reengage them
as they come back to your
service in the future.
So things like sending
the user emails
if they've opted into that
about upcoming sales, deals,
price changes, or
maybe a reminder
to buy flowers for
your mom this weekend.
So if you put all
these pieces together,
you get this smooth,
personalized experience
where you know your user,
you can improve checkout
and conversion
rates, and you can
keep users engaged and secure.
After all, in a world where
they don't even have passwords,
they won't be
phished, or you won't
have problems with those
weak and reused passwords.
So leave it to Luke to wrap up
today and tell you a little bit
about what we covered.
LUKE CAMERY: Thank you guys
for explaining all this to me.
I feel like I
learned a lot here.
It's a really seamless
user experience
where you can just
skip the sign-in,
don't even have to think about
it; transparent data sharing,
you know exactly what
you're giving away
and what you're keeping private;
and you get all these security
benefits on the side.
And for developers, you get all
these account quality benefits.
So Steven, where
do I go to start?
STEVEN SONEFF: Well
the place to go,
we've mentioned a
few times today is
developers.google.com/identity.
That's where you'll find
the documentation for all
of the APIs that
we've described,
and case studies and examples
with many of the partners
that we've referenced.
And since you're here at I/O,
there's a couple of other talks
that you'd probably like
to visit and check out.
We have some coming up
tomorrow around building
and personalizing an
action, leveraging
the same ideas and the same
underlying Google Identity;
as well as a deep dive into this
experience on the web that I've
been talking about today.
So if you've got time,
definitely check those out
tomorrow and we'd love to
continue the conversation.
So we monitor the Stack
Overflow tag Google-Identity.
Make sure to leave
your questions there,
that's the best
place to put them out
in front of the community.
And our contact information
is up here on the slides.
You can send us an email.
I'm sso@google.com.
We would love to hear from you.
And we'll be in the web sandbox
after this, or around the stage
if you've got questions
that you'd like to ask us.
That's tent G over on that side.
So thank you very much
for your attention today.
We'd love to hear
from you and be
able to show your site
or your app up here
next year at I/O
about how you've
made identity a more secure and
easy experience for your users.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]